foreign
Denver councilwoman proposes taxing
quote white LED businesses as
reparations in order to support minority
Enterprises
so this is this is in Denver I said
right she's a city councilwoman her name
is Candy wait wait does it count if if
if uh they don't if white people don't
have businesses
uh no it does not count ah I can't why
can't they wouldn't it be better to tax
white owned Corporation
my own business it seems like there's
gonna go after like a flower shop I hope
that that's what they do because that
makes more sense yeah there's too many
of them well then but then but then but
then doesn't that mean all the
businesses in Colorado are just gonna
leave but shouldn't they pay up Joe
think about it do you think they should
wait wait wait wait wait wait oh yeah
I'm a minor let me get up they should
pay they should give you some context
let me give you guys some context so
this Council woman says that capitalism
was built on Stolen lands stolen labors
and stolen resources and they checked
today could not undo the cumulative
impact of generations of that stolen
wolf in all of those categories and
she's she's saying this as she seeks
reelection mind you um she is a person
who is up for election so so you see why
this is one of her platforms is she
white she is not her name is uh CD Baca
I believe I said
her name is Candy citibaca she is
say what race she is because that could
be racist
just take it your best game I'll show
you what she looks like
she looks and it's it's so good that I'm
that I am not commenting
because she looks hella Indian to me I
think she is Indian
oh like Native American yeah yeah like
it like an engine oh I see you know I
thought it was the other kind of yeah
yeah
you guys remember you know what I'm
talking about yeah I think so yeah so
she
wants to go after the white gas station
owner
yeah
why can't they go They're Gonna tax
their [__] flaming hot Cheetos that
they sell pretty much great big business
sounds more lucrative as it to tax
anyways what do you think about that
though I don't know I'm trying to find
the Asian equivalent like would it be
like if uh I mean Japanese were the
colonists of the rest of Asia yeah so
that means I just got to pay you guys
better or do you think that it's a start
job should every white it's a good idea
it doesn't count well Steve's wife so
you don't have to pay him more but oh
please please do though
should every white owned sushi
restaurant have to pay Japanese sushi
restaurants in the same area that would
be nice a tax for existing there's a tax
there's a cultural tax yeah you know
what it is like licensing yeah they'd be
splitting the customer the consumer base
it's like cultural licensing because
it's like hey we own the brand right so
then you have to pay but it's such an
old recipe that's a good idea actually
seaweed and rice yeah who the [__] owns
that's true that's like saying how you
know how like Mickey Mouse is about to
be in public domain because like what
yeah because it's like 100 years old so
you can only do it for so long and like
within like 10 years Mickey Mouse can be
in public domain so Disney [__] bricks
obviously about it yeah Peter Pan's been
public domain for a while right so the
another um huge cartoon just became
public domain it's Batman Batman is
public domain now really the original
comments oh here's the original Bob Kane
comic yeah it came out like 1920
something holy [__] did you say public
domain you're talking about things like
uh in terms of like copyrights I'm
saying Kansas could do a Batman movie
now but you have to do it through the
source material so it has to be like
Batman with purple gloves yeah the
original the OG yeah oh
Comics number one it's like how like we
and choreographed to [__] a really
really old school classic songs because
they're all public domain yeah that's
why everyone uses house the Rising Sun
because like that's a free song right or
Danny Boy yep
there there is a there is there there
are instances of reparations that happen
um for the Japanese American Community
because I think it was so
um recent that they were able to trace
it so it was like internment okay I was
like this family lost this much girl so
they because they got in turn so then
when they got out it's like they got
something back but then it was never the
equivalent of what their properties
would have been worth if they were able
to keep their land not to mention the
stigma post World War II yeah like how
much of that impact and the Farms
because I feel like the unfortunate
thing about
like if you say
reparations for the black community
right the paperwork was horrible back
then how do you trace the lineage how do
you and then also like
is it only uh if you just if you just
make like a blanket one like black right
but what about all the Africans that
just came over they're gonna qualify for
it when they weren't their ancestors
were you have to be foundational black
yeah but how do they trace that though
that's the hard part I think there's 23
I mean yeah it didn't sound like they
were trying to be that I guess specific
at least when when I saw that court that
court hearing of the dude that wanted
reparations it was like every black
American that's foundational black
American
and they're not I don't I don't think
it's gonna be divided that
that I see
dang I mean if they could find out a way
to make a balance but but do you think
that that the white owned businesses
should be taxed or should that be
something another thing a separate thing
well I don't actually believe that
all white people had it good well I also
don't think especially people who had to
work for their small business yeah yeah
a degree though it's like now they have
to pay an additional tax because of just
a foundation or some sort of line that
somebody's drawing yeah the way I see
history is like there was a very very
small handful of people that owned
everybody and then it wasn't like it was
like yeah maybe one group had it a
little bit better but everyone had a
hard hard hard time that was shitty and
everyone was enslaved by this small
group I think also that that's
overlooking the the savviness of
business owners like let's say like that
soccer player dude is an example of like
how he got a divorce and his wife was
like I'm taking all your [__] and he's
like well I don't technically own it oh
because he put it in his mom's exactly
when you get to a point in business
you're not it's not easy to get your
[__] let alone tax you for [__] like oh
that's what you're saying so like attach
my business here you go and then the
what's going to be on paper is not what
you were expecting right there's gonna
be some sort of loophole so it's like
it's like even if the law goes through
yeah you're saying that these white
owned businesses can say can register in
Delaware or whatever still operate in
Colorado but technically they can't be
taxed by Colorado anymore like I think
that's like five percent the battle also
you may just never get your money yeah
who's whose job is it to go after the
actual actual cash yeah I do think
though like like sometimes things are uh
they have good motivations but poor
execution and this happens a lot in
government right so like let's say a lot
of these programs that are meant to help
the the the poor and the needy never the
money never gets to them yeah so like
she might be doing this just cause thing
people might be voting for it but the
people that are executing it could be
corrupt could be incompetent because
we've seen this time again in government
we're like yeah there's so much funding
that goes to the poor communities in
California the homeless problem here is
[__] just getting crazier but they
spend billions of dollars but none of
that money goes to actually helping them
and it just goes to these massive
parties that politicians do so yeah
because they got funding the first thing
you're gonna see if something like this
were to go through is you're going to
see commercials for lawyers that can go
I'm gonna help you get your money that
is owed to you and they're gonna be
making the money not getting you the
money yeah like you'll just be paying
them like a class action lawsuit well
does this also does this speak for
everybody right does everyone is
everybody who's a a business owner in
the city they're like yes I do want uh
attacks on White owned businesses so
that they can pay me some extra extra
cash right like like of course not so
the idea of this is kind of whackity do
in that way too where it's like not
everybody you're assuming that they all
want a check from these people or
whatever you're assuming they agree with
your platform and they agree with what
you're saying that's true what's the
majority demographic in that area
um
uh uh it'll probably take me like
[__] two well it's called enough it's
it's well you said Colorado right yeah I
don't when I went out there it's very
liberal but it's a lot of white people
also people can be Liberal Liberal on
the Forefront as much as they want they
can say they support these things but in
the back end when they do their business
it may not match what they say their
politics are yeah like Silicon Valley
and NorCal they're just like yeah 72
white okay uh African-American 9.18 so
good luck and other races best of luck I
said get those whites wait doesn't that
make it easier though if the majority of
the the populists out there are like
probably white owned businesses that
means that fractionally they'll probably
take less of a tax to provide for less
of the people no but she's saying that
they're not going to vote for it exactly
but Colorado is like Oregon it's so woke
that they might even vote for it for the
white Guild dude that's true white Guild
is very strong I don't have white guilt
I think it's very powerful I have the
opposite it's called white pride
is that okay can I say that dude I
talked to a lot of people with white
guilt isn't that kind of like self-love
they'll vote for this
they'll definitely vote for this yeah
that's a crazy thing I mean clearly it's
somebody this person who's saying this
is someone that's running in politics
right yeah so it's just a demonstration
of their values they don't I doubt they
really care if they'll ever achieve this
implement it well also though it's like
this is one of those things where like
if a white person was trying to put this
into motion it would maybe be like white
saviorism and guilt whereas
because because it's not a white person
but because it's I also like like you
said it's probably a Native American
person I said engine
[Laughter]
it's one of the situations where it's
like you know they have a certain type
of Precedence to like say something that
you kind of got to respect well she's
allowed to say that she's allowed to
fight for that you know and it makes
sense you know how about like the most
simplest pragmatic thing I've always
thought about is everybody use their tax
dollars to help the poor community
and forbid better education better
hospitals better resources because if
you ever travel through the poor
communities they don't have the same
[__] that we do in the middle class and
above it's this so it's like and we're
all sharing the same country and we want
people to do better right and we want
the quality of lives of these other
communities to do better so I'm like why
don't we just start there
I don't know why is that so hard you're
trying to solve a problem Joe and I
think that sometimes you need to have
problems that aren't solved so that you
can run on them again and then you can
run on them
is that one that you were always saying
too that like
I think one of the worst things is that
if you choose to work that's not enough
it's not enough to make your life better
that's what sucks right what do you mean
by that like if I'm let's say I'm I'm a
super low income person and I decide I
would like to work in order to not be
low income that is nothing to solve my
problem because most of the jobs that I
can get at an entry level do not satisfy
the requirements to have an everyday
life they priced you out of the market
already yeah you're priced out oh yeah
yeah like a lot of poor people won't be
able to live this yeah you're not fun
living yeah yeah that's for sure right
poorer people have to spend more time
taking care of other things because they
can't use money to solve those right
like babysitting or like anything else
that you could just throw money at to
have someone else worry about it they
don't have that luxury so it's like now
you can't work as many jobs
it's just a different game all the way
that's true also maybe this is like a
different old school mentality but like
does it have to be so and I get it the
conversation is so like topical in
America but does it have to be like a
race driven versus like uh
socioeconomics yeah like attacks the
rich right put the what the top one
percent in just a different tax bracket
that gets taxable which I know kind of
happens already if you make more than
you get taxed in the type of bracket
whatever but that would make sense right
because then more money comes from those
that can afford it to potentially
provide for those resources I've said
this a couple times one of my favorite
trolling bits I never got to do was take
a megaphone into a like basically a
mobile home uh Park
and start yelling at white people about
their white privilege and [__] because
because exactly right like yeah exactly
the whole thing is like I I as the
tornado when we focus too much on Race
what ends up happening is divide and
conquer right working class why working
class minorities they're out here
fighting for crumbs and also we can't
look at uh
business owners as they're the enemies
either because we need both we need
working class to work alongside
businesses we need to work together
right but I also feel like the elites
that are both in government in the
public sector and the private sector
they're working together so it's more of
class Warfare and you can say let's tax
the rich but identifying who the rich is
and who's on the the side of the people
you can't really tell and also
billionaires they have the they have the
uh resources to be offshore so you can
put as many tax laws and [__] as you
want on the loopholes no that's why the
IRS goes after the middle class and
small businesses because they'll get it
so much easier to extract them they'll
get it yeah you you think they could
come after Amazon they're going to be
spending decades fighting them not
getting paid is there any good is there
any purpose in Greater taxes for foreign
companies using America yeah
for their business well that's supposed
to be the tariffs and the yeah and the
international tax law and stuff like
that is there is there negative uh
blowback to raising those
I mean there are things in place but
like you got to look at each because for
example right like one of the stuff in
the 90s the reason why Korea and Samsung
and all those guys started to come up is
because they felt threatened by the
Japanese electronics Industry and the
car manufacturers so these foreign
companies they made up all these rules
like let's say uh BMW and all these guys
most of your cars have to be made in the
States because we don't want foreign
manufacturers taking away jobs whatever
like they blocked I think it was Bush
they blocked all the cell phones and TVs
and Sony's and everything from Japan and
that's when they got contracts from
Samsung and all them to come in that's
why we don't see Japanese phones anymore
There are rules and things like that in
place that governments take during
Trump's Administration he was saying
like there's a huge trade deficit
between us and China to the point where
um they're like we're just in these
shitty contracts where there's more
money that's leaving the states than
we're making from China is there an
equivalent to like let's say when you
tax California companies too much they
leave California and that's bad for
California does that happen with other
countries businesses in America
that happens in every industry in
general right like that's a huge topic
on things like uh like crypto right now
the crypto space you [__] regulate it
you over regulate it too much in America
suddenly all the Innovation goes to
every other foreign country it's the
same [__] back and forth oh okay okay so
it's going to happen
um EV tax credits for cars and stuff
like that like you'll get a tax credit
if that was manufactured in California
the batteries and everything like that
you won't get it if you purchase a
cheaper version of those manufacturers
yeah I got it so it works both ways it's
just a matter of like how but on the
flip side though we do make a lot of
money through tax it's just
mismanagement of funds that's a big part
of it too if you look at how much money
is being wasted by government and
um have you heard of use it or lose it
programs you know like in production and
film right like if you don't use that
full budget then they go next year you
don't need that much to make that film
so they spend frivolously like schools
all that stuff they'll have a whole new
set of computers chairs desks and
they're just like let's toss it we need
to buy more or else we're going to lose
this budget so government wastes a lot
of money in tax dollars too so it's like
you can't just look at one side and go
it's the rich people it's the
billionaires it's this it's the whole
[__] system that everybody's milky
yep 100 regulate that
you tax the whites
hey we're gonna need to spend about uh
200 000 in c47s okay that's right are
those are clothing yeah
[Music]